I am general machen on today I will
speak to you about a muttered rarity I'm
passionate about it on especially web of
muttered rarity so what is web augmented
reality versus augmented reality
pictures better than words so here below
you have blood rather and you have a
wonderful ear Oh looking at a very big
Allah Graham he has no device on the
head nor device on your hand everything
is working well well that's cool but
that's Hollywood unfortunately so this
is what augmented reality could be we
would like it to be like that for
Hollywood that's specially fight for the
real world and that's a good definition
of augmented reality you would mount
reality by adding information on top of
it so let's see what clock w was to
serve address this is a possible
application of what augmented reality
could be or would be in the future
so check review suppose you are in a
shop and you see a lot of product on the
shelf you take your phone you point your
phone at the product and suddenly you
see the world view from your friend so
review from other people wet on the
internet suddenly you make a more
knowledgeable choice about to purchase
or better use of your money another well
suppose you want to wash some clothes
and you have a tag on your clothes most
of the time it is quite cryptic and you
do not understand it will be great if I
can point my phone axis tag and suddenly
it is explained to me
in plain words once again I avoid a
lower rate so this is nice this is a
dream this is what reality will be in
the future but let's see about what it
is today and today for at least for me
augmented reality can be run in ten line
of HTML so this is quite important first
because this is tan line on Sudan
because this is a sh t ml let me explain
why
so this is what you see on the screen is
a basic example of a rjs so you have
only ten line of HTML
this is a basic script here body any web
def can do it and if you do this
wonderful example you will have this
result so a basic cube on top of a
marker this is a very basic example
because this is only tan line but you
can build significant application in the
very little line this is a point here
let me come back to this one this is
important because this is tan line
so tonight is short so you can learn on
Ted page that somewhere and this is our
channel so it mean anybody on the planet
anybody who is a web developer can do
this this is short and simple to
understand on any web developer can do
it this is definitely point here you can
see Aleksandra my wife doing that inside
cut pen so you take this basic example
you place that into Capel and certainly
you can do a mozzarella t on the left of
materiality is easy where they are
chairs at least I try to make it easy
let me show you this videos that we used
you know in order to have Wi-Fi know we
have Wi-Fi so here you have a marker
we've no freaking table
and if you look at your marker
sousaphone drugs augmented reality you
can move around this is 60 FPS so it's
working on on old phones very important
full open source and based on web
standout we will see all the advantage
of a spatula in to talk on dot forget a
phone without much energy it's fun
enough okay let me try to okay so when I
did they are Jess what was in my head is
some other things first I wanted to
realize my dream about a hour meaning
that for the controversial reason I had
a lot of free time and I wanted to build
a are as it should be where they are so
it should be so I use on drug part of my
free time to do that and but in my head
when I did that it was a lot like being
a drug let me explain why when I did
this project just I forgot to say it's
open source so I had to look compose on
unruffled on the surface but below
I had to paddle like hell because this
was an open source project so I did that
with my two hand and under the hood I
had a lot of responsibilities I had to
do fixing bad I had to do testing to
improve the accuracy of the camera
tracking so augmented reality accuracy
all of this software engineering stuff
this was longer than grateful as be
honest but it was needed so I did it but
yes
so I was alone to hand out doing all the
design or jaw structure also called
working ten hours a day not making a
penny because I happened to be
unemployed
but good for the free time health center
point but for me LGS was realized my
dream to make a are as easy as possible
because I believe it has to be easy so
let's look deeper on what is our chairs
first mission the mission of AES is to
bring air to the web or to make where
they are a reality so for that I wanted
to make energy as very fast web-based
open-source and realizing and
stalled-out force as a principle and try
to apply so first very fast while it has
to be very fast is because when you do
augmented reality basically you need to
work that at 60fps or close if you do
that at 5 PS this is boring and this is
not moving well so you are not in mass
if you already know that a trick if you
are 60 FPS this is a lot better for
ability so when I took it it was 5 PS on
an eye on phone on right now this is 60
FPS even on a two-year-old phone
additionally LGS is web-based what does
this mean this mean this is full
JavaScript and this is a pure web
solution it has plan consequences when
you are on the phone when you are on the
phone you don't want to install
application this is not something you
like all statistics shows that to
install application is really some
things that people don't want to do on
the more it goes with time so let's
install applications so to be pure pure
web is very nice additionally it is
relying on standard this means that any
web browser can with WebGL on WebRTC can
do way out yes there is no need so
specifically a public API sorry or
specific application
modern web browser is enough this means
that a RGS work on Android Windows Phone
on iOS so basically every phone of the
planet it's good now you know how it all
started
but what happened after the beginning of
our chairs
well 2017 has been a big year for motor
reality and at the middle of the year in
June 2017
Apple announced a our kit so what is the
accurate
this is markerless tracking mikelis
tracking means that you can take your
phone you don't need to print a marker
to look at your marker you switch on
your phone and you can have a granted
relative right there and to middle of
the street I our kit as well as
something we call it testing so it
testing is the phone is able to
understand the topology of the world
meaning is able to detect the plane on
the ground is about to detect a table
and you can put augmented reality on the
table on the ground whatever
another interesting aspect is racket
will be will be is available on
monocular camera we will see more about
what is a monocular camera man so racket
when it has been announced it was really
really really big it for augmented
reality it was a bump in the world why
because of materiality was by default on
the phone in your pocket before a
hatchet to havoc materiality you needed
to have a specific devices Pacific
device on you had a specific form but we
they are cheap
you got ignited reality by default there
is no need for anything else so yeah it
was a very first step for massive user
adoption all that faith to the monocular
camera support everybody was rightfully
in prayer
and in August 2017 Google replied with
air crawl so two months after that and
in for all normal purposes they are
co-owner a kid are very very similar
from a factual point of view but it was
very good from augmented reality echo
system because before Apple was under
multiple and suddenly said you don't
have it anymore we are Google and Apple
kelabra collaborating competing with
each other it's very important
Google is with Android 88% of the world
one market an iPhone is 12% but both of
them competing with each other is good
for see a consistent diversity and
competition is healthy for the users Co
system as well
another advantage with this announcement
of air crore is Google exposing
augmented reality to the web we are all
on our kid native API is not something
that you can easily reach from the web
because Google is so very keen at the
web they build to application in which
they expose Eric watch it to web browser
most application suite name of where
they are on air core and where they are
on achieved will can feel that an
engineer kind of world so what are those
application where they are near crow is
a chromium modified to read air crawl on
exposure to two column where they are on
arch it is reading air jet unless it is
expressing that to an iOS web view what
is interesting from the web a our point
of view is they expose air co-ownership
with the exact same api so when you
build you
a application on the web you need to
build it only once and it will work on
those two application on a across on iOS
or on a aqua on-air kid
let's look at some example so this is a
typical application that you can build
that in whatever I have a bunch of video
so I hope we can have Wi-Fi apparently
not
come on be nice with me this is not nice
with me so this is a wonderful
application in which you can fetch you
can throw a stick on you god I'm trying
again come on
that would be a very sad talk if I don't
have okay
partly YouTube doesn't go through
anymore so let me comment on the picture
so what is a keypad so basically you are
a very cute dog and you throw a virtual
stick to this virtual pet on the go
fetch and come back the video is very
cute on am evilly sad very sad
okay alright we're gonna try this ammo
here it's another video let's try this
one
oh this one is working I don't get it
ugly cool let's be appear bad so this
one is a portal so here's the iron
Englund and they see that materiality
door meaning that your portal to another
reality I foolish you see San Francisco
and you see Sir Francis course was a
portal but you can a well walk through
this wonderful portal and you piggy you
I in San Francisco the bird is really
too and San Francisco you can route
around and be in San Francisco you can
recognize a bridge and see the portal on
your back in England
it's a fastest way to travel okay let's
be up full on the video staff this other
video is a teresting for the realism
always grown flying around look quite
immersive I mean you don't see them as I
don't know talking too much 3d because
this really is used something called PBR
which make it very realistic when you
look matted relative justly it's very
important to be as well stick as
possible this way you are a lot more
immersive the arrows are air heat
apparently this was only occur but
almost demo can be done on air crawl and
air kit so after a occur on an arcade
what should we do with a RGS well we
made a RGS evolve since we parted that
to a frame API we parted that as well to
Babylon so you can use a GS with three
GS a frame and Babylon J's its report a
our kit on our craw - so this is quite
good because let me explain so my
kitchen not sure about that
what is interesting is when you do an
application with a RGS you can support
every tracking possible we have your
LG's application when you are on air
core device LGS will use air core
tracking if you are on an iOS device it
will use our keep tracking and if you
are on a normal phone which is not
supporting our on air kit it will use
pure web tracking
so now chess will provide the best
tracking available on your device no
matter what device you have
which is nice about this is when you
build your application you don't need to
build one application for their CRO
another for your kit and another for
Joseph phones you have a single
application which report of the
available tracking you write your
application once or it will run on every
platform here is another example YouTube
Twitter is working but youtube is
failing
what okay this one is working through so
this is in my apartment and when you do
a mounted reality it is let's say a
tradition to do a tsunami KU I'm not
sure why
so this one is actually Miku dancing in
my apartment it has been done on trongo
device and you can see you can be close
you can hear a thing you can see my cut
this one is real and I have to cut
search if you want to love more this is
my first video of with affair GS with a
our crow
yes not very impressive but as it is my
first demo so it's basically the cube
floating in the air inside my apartment
so what can you do with energy s one
thing that I like to do is refraction
because when you talk mantle reality one
things you really need to do is to match
the virtual on the real meanings that
you want anything that you add to the
real world to appear as real as possible
so one aspect that I did is refraction
we okay cool so refraction is not
arresting because here you have
obviously big tourists please Victoria
sees obviously not real but I did it
it's such a juicy spool it appears a
glass
so you see fools are 3d this way this
really seems a lot more included into
the real so you see and after that you
can see my wife at the end so you see
through and you can see the 3d and
suddenly it's become a lot more real yes
Erica that's yet it is rather simple to
do this one is when you do augmented
reality you like to do something magical
as well here this is a background my
table but I use some 3d tricks to make
it appears as inside the whole that's an
effect called hole in the wall so you
use some 3d tricks which way you believe
that is included inside the table but
obviously it is not gone after certain
dose really experts of 3d years in
Butler expect so I do stupid models like
rubber jack which will model guy contact
me please
oh so this one is a version of the
portal in SL fashion but this one is
done by a yes yes YouTube is working
again so this one is on marker but you
can use of the streets or something for
arte aqua we go through suddenly we are
in another world but still with these
are real worlds with a portal and we
gonna come back on every time you switch
from a web to the others that's like a
bridge between two world
oops here we go
that's a friend that I have on my desk
so which kind of force application can
you build now we got where they are this
is good because you can build
application on any mobile phone
but which kind of application do you
wanna build because you got tracking on
you good you do portals you do drawing
but it's not really useful so you can do
a are gaming so a are gaming obviously
you may have heard of Pokemon go that's
one and also one is for example this
game those game has not been done by air
chess but you can definitely consume but
we've a obviously if you have the time
on the Internet
this is on pace Vita so they use marker
in order to interact with a with a game
so you move your marker on the table
it moves the object on Ulysses laaser
game so these last a being I don't know
how to say that protected you describe
stuff like that
in short your markers are a new way a
new input so this is a lousy game let me
show you other games this one is a
strike race it's a race track after we
had right okay so this was interesting
because this is dynamics so you move the
back around and you change the shape of
the track another game for example when
you yes he's doing that if you are paid
but on also ahead
so you can see that the pet is following
you when you are moving the Macra around
oh I don't know here 51 version inside
your retrimmed about it
probably not okay so when you do that
for example so we have seen games or
stuff like that see is one good
application that you can do is education
because suppose you are in
cool you put a marker inside your book
on instead of reading a sentence like I
don't know
such qing conquest such a country you
can actually do an animation something
funny which can entertain the kids
this way the kid will be less bored
which happen quite often when you are
doing school so it's a very good way to
contact just get to for example so
that's an example and so you can see
some markers on you see an animation
directly on top of the book which is
obviously much more entertaining you got
this one and so you can use a
materiality for example in the industry
it has been shown that with proper
etcetera if you are in the under screen
you'll reduce quite significantly so
error rate so definitely interesting you
can use it for commerce on e-commerce as
well or you can use in for medical
training of subs and also well so well
it all mountain reality right now need
better application we have the tracking
which is good you can produce good
augmented reality on any phone you don't
need to have the latest iPhone or Google
pixel or and so on you can start to
build your Barton reality today and you
need to be highly creative that's what
we need at the moment
and we not gonna have questions so
that's the end of my talk partly I
completed results thank you
you